she doesn't even go here just do that a
party as the mail and if they don't know
Halloween can be super stressful you
have to put together a whole costume
weeks in advance and sometimes it costs
a lot of money but I'm going to tell you
people you don't have to do all that
these Halloween costumes are budget
friendly and can be put together in
literally 30 seconds and honestly I
think they're kind of clever you ready
for this I don't think so
it's gonna be awesome time me this is
gonna be awesome
oh my god I have fake nails on this is
impossible with fake nails don't do this
with fake nails
it's 2 Chainz see when they're like who
are you you like I'm su Shane's cuz I've
got no DOS James I don't know how to say
that they didn't teach me that on
duolingo what got a Dana God Dana's God
cárdenas dos cadenas yeah say it like
that sexy like me
get it avocado toast this is funny I
love this one mm-hmm
[Music]
get it
Regina George for Mean Girls and I'm
making this cool that's right mom you're
welcome this is your baby girl are they
off their knit they're knit I didn't
have I didn't have enough they're
supposed to be up here they're supposed
to be you know what make sure they're in
the right spot don't do this
but you know what I'm saying it's like
easy to do you're welcome
[Music]
dr. pepper the breakfast of champions in
Texas did you know the dr. pepper museum
is in dr. Cooper what if I said dr.
pepper museum easy in day house it is
I've been there that's right Jamie to
take a bite of this I don't care I'm not
gonna do it bread winner just wear this
bad boy just chuck it in real nice and
then just like hold your loaves and
you're like what are you I'm the
breadwinner that's right
don't you hate when you're a female and
you go to stores and like oh your
husband doesn't mind that you shop like
this I'm like girl this is my money why
do they do that it is not the 50s
it is almost 2020 it is my money
oh I buy my stuff with it but I can't
stand it
[Music]
Damian for Mean Girls she doesn't even
go here just do that a party I still
know and if they don't know
these are funny costumes all the time
and money I've spent every frickin
Halloween on like amazing costumes and
these are better because they're funny
can you imagine just walk around a party
with some bread and a trophy like I'm
the breadwinner that's funny I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this